[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
ihren apparaten
samstagabend und willkommen den sport
gibt's von norbert lehmann und auch von
mir wie geht man die großen probleme
dieser welt an der g20 gipfel eines
unserer themen heute
klima corona globale steuern beim
treffen der g 20 in rom stehen die
wichtigsten wirtschaftsmächte vor großen
herausforderungen
cdu-basis will mitsprache nach dem
wahl-debakel fordern die
kreisvorsitzenden den nächsten
parteichef per mitgliederentscheid zu
bestimmen
und dramatische corona lage in russland
die zahlen erreichen immer neue
höchststände seit heute gilt ein
landesweiter zwangsurlaub
nach mehr als zwei jahren findet der g
20 gipfel wieder in präsenz statt so
dass sich die staats und
regierungschefinnen und chefs der
mächtigsten länder wieder in gesprächen
am rande abstimmen können für die
diplomatie unglaublich wichtig aber von
denen 20 sind nur 15 vor ort zwei
besonders wichtige fehlen russlands
präsident putin und der chinesische
staatschef zu nehmen nur virtuell teil
die liste der themen ist lang
klimaschutz kampf gegen korona und die
globale unternehmensteuer aus rom anne
gellinek
gerade hatten sich die chefs und chefin
der g 20 zum sogenannten familienfoto
aufgestellt da bittet die italienische
gipfel regie noch mehr teilnehmer auf
die bühne ärzte krankenschwestern und
rettungssanitäter die im besonders von
corona betroffenen italien gegen die
krankheit gekämpft hatten applaus für
mediziner und pflegepersonal uns elfi
schmidt us-präsident beiden zum auftakt
des g20 gipfels die impfstoff
verteilungen der welt noch immer
ungerecht nur drei prozent der menschen
in ärmeren ländern sind geimpft die g20
müssten hier noch mehr tun mahnt
gastgeber mario draghi beim ersten
persönlichen treffen seit zwei jahren
appelliert trage an den gespaltenen g20
club sich dieses mal zusammen zu raufen
egal ob pandemie klimawandel oder faire
und gerechte besteuerung es allein zu
versuchen
ist einfach keine option ist simply
norden option eine globale mindeststeuer
von 50 prozent ist beschlossen immerhin
beim klimaschutz jedoch liegen die g20
noch weit auseinander auf mehr als ein
bemühen die erderwärmung zu begrenzen
kann man sich nicht einigen der
chinesische und der russische präsident
zeigen demonstratives desinteresse an
der klimadebatte und lassen sich nur per
video zuschalten es ist merkels letzter
großer gipfel und sie nutzt die
gelegenheit der welt den vermutlich
künftigen deutschen regierungschef
vorzustellen zu einer ganzen reihe von
gesprächen darunter eines mit dem
amerikanischen präsidenten kommen merkel
und scholz im doppelpack für merkel ist
es ein abschied für scholz ein crashkurs
in sachen kanzler
und dem beitrag hat sich ein fehler
eingeschlichen die globale mindeststeuer
beträgt natürlich 15 prozent so jetzt
gehen wir nach rom zuschauer und
annabella die erster g20-gipfel nach
tromm sind die usa unter präsident
beiden wieder stärker an zusammenarbeit
interessiert
ja da erfüllte beiden ganz eindeutig die
erwartungen zumindest die europäer schon
vor allem mit dem klaren zeichen dass er
hier gesetzt hat mit dem gemeinsamen
treffen mit deutschland frankreich und
großbritannien zum iranischen
nuklearprogramm
das hätte es unter trump nicht gegeben
ist ein deutliches zeichen der abkehr
vom tram kurs und auch die neue rolle
als antreiber die er hier in der
klimaschutzpolitik vorlegten immer ein
nationales ehrgeiziges
klimaschutzprogramm zumindest
verabschiedet hat und skizziert hat die
unterscheidet sich doch sehr vom tram
kurs und das zeigt dass er hier auftritt
als jemand der die usa nicht nur wieder
zurückbringen will an den multilateralen
verhandlungstisch sondern der für die
usa auch eine sehr viel aktivere rolle
vorsieht jetzt ist der klimaschutz ein
großes thema beim gipfel was ist denn
deutschland bereit zu leisten
ja salopp gesagt ist deutschland strebe
uns sünder zugleich denn auf der einen
seite will deutschland klimaneutral
werden bis 20.45 das ist deutlich früher
als zum beispiel die eu oder andere
staaten wie china
und auf der anderen seite muss man aber
auch dazu sagen dass dafür noch einige
hausaufgaben zu machen sind denn dass
die nationalen klimaschutzziele
deutschlands müssen erst einmal
nachgebessert werden um selber möglichst
schnell auf den 1,5 grad zu kommen und
da stellt sich die große frage wie genau
wird das passieren die kann man hier
kaum beantworten denn angela merkel geht
demnächst olaf scholz ist noch nicht
gewählt und zu hause in berlin da
verhandelt gerade seine spd erst mit fdp
und grünen auch über ein mögliches
künftiges
klimaschutzprogramm der der möglichen
ampel also da werden die g-20 wohl auf
eine klare linie deutschland zur zukunft
zum zukünftigen beitrag zum klimaschutz
noch eine weile warten müssen ich danke
für diese einschätzung talabani ausruhen
auf der internationalen bühne wird die
union bald wohl nicht mehr viel zu sagen
haben aufgrund der historischen schlappe
bei der bundestagswahl die aufarbeitung
läuft so haben sich heute die
kreisvorsitzenden der cdu getroffen und
mit großer mehrheit dafür ausgesprochen
den neuen parteivorsitz per
mitgliederbefragung zu bestimmen ines
trams über die basis
in demonstration vor der konferenz von
ostdeutschen kreisvorsitzenden fühlten
sie sich doch oft in der vergangenheit
nicht gehört die basis muss eingebunden
werden wir brauchen keine partei der
funktionäre wir brauchen eine partei die
funktioniert es gilt für ihn einen
nachfolger als parteichef zu finden über
300 kreisvorsitzende reisten nach berlin
um das verfahren dafür zu beraten eine
mitgliederbefragung steht zur diskussion
meinungen also die mitglieder so ist das
zumindest dass ich verspüre wollen
einfach mal ein bisschen mehr
mitentscheiden sie wollen nicht nur bei
bei wind und regen plakate aufhängen
sondern sie wollen tatsächlich mal
mitbestimmen ich glaube wir würden uns
über monate hin eine personaldebatte
begeben die die ganze partei leben wird
wir werden nicht über inhalte reden
sondern über personen es gärt an der
basis viele mitglieder fühlten sich
übergangen bei armin laschet wahl zum
parteichef und dann zum
kanzlerkandidaten das historisch
schlechte wahlergebnis tat ein übriges
fünf stunden beratung im ballsaal des
berliner hotels dann stimmen die
kreisvorsitzenden mit großer mehrheit
für eine mitgliederbefragung daran
kommen die gremien nun kaum vorbei heute
ist der erste tag der erneuerung der cdu
wir schlagen mit dem heutigen tag ein
neues kapitel auf ein neues kapitel der
mitgliederbeteiligung auch bei denen die
zuvor die mitglieder nicht befragen
wollten nun zufriedenheit der wunsch
nach geschlossenheit überlagert alles
wir hatten so gut miteinander diskutiert
wie schon lange nicht mehr auch in der
form und ich glaube dass von der
veranstaltung heute eine
aufbruchstimmung die partei angehen wird
die cdu steht nun vor der
herausforderung zügig vor den drei
anstehenden landtagswahlen eine
mitgliederbefragung zu organisieren
die basis will also mitreden theo koll
in berlin was bedeutet das dann jetzt
konkret für die suche nach einer neuen
zählung parteispitze
konkret war das heute die entscheidende
weichenstellung und bedeutet dass der
nächste parteivorsitzende zum ersten mal
in der cdu geschichte de facto von der
basis bestimmt wird nach dem
parteiengesetz darf das zwar nur der
parteitag aber der kann dann gar nicht
mehr anders als die entscheidung der
rund 400.000 mitglieder zu
berücksichtigen am dienstag sollen die
führungsgremien den genauen prozess
festlegen und dann müssten sich mögliche
kandidaten sehr schnell aus der deckung
wagen einen mitgliederentscheid hilft
natürlich er den an der parteibasis
beliebten kandidaten aktuell liegen
friedrich merz und norbert röttgen in
den umfragen vorn einige cdu abgeordnete
haben übrigens darauf hingewiesen dass
es höchstwahrscheinlich jetzt eh nur um
einen übergangs vorsitzenden gehe den
nach langen kanzler schafften und nach
einer verlorenen wahl sei der nächste
vorsitzende noch nie kanzler geworden
dankeschön theo koll
wegen wir jetzt auf die krone pandemie
in den usa hat jetzt neu mittelbehörde
fdp grünes licht gegeben für den biotech
pfizer impfstoff für kinder von fünf bis
elf jahren ihre dosis ist ein drittel so
groß wie die für erwachsene
der impfschutz liege bei gut 90 prozent
so bei und texter endgültig wird der
impfstoff für kinder den usa will
kommende woche durch die
gesundheitsbehörde freigegeben in
deutschland bekommt unterdessen
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen kritik
für sein appell sich eine
auffrischungsimpfung geben zu lassen
dadurch würden erwartungen geschürt eine
dritte impfung sei für alle möglich
heißt es von ärztevertreter reload
vertretern die korona zahlen steigen
zurzeit weiter sprunghaft an
21.500 43 neue fälle meldet das rk ii
das sind 6000 398 mehr als vergangenen
samstag bei der incidents zeigt die
kurve in den letzten tagen wieder steil
nach oben wie sie auch hier sehen können
aktueller wert
145,1 vor zwei wochen lag er noch bei
70,8 und vermehrt trifft es wieder
ältere menschen alko bisa
das seniorenheim in schorfheide in
brandenburg mehr als 40 bewohner sind
infiziert 8 sollen bereits gestorben
sein es sind diese besonders gefährdeten
gruppen die sich mit einer dritten
impfung dem sogenannten booster schützen
sollten der vorstoß von
gesundheitsminister sparen dass sich
auch unter 70 jährige diese spritze
abholen könnten wird von ärzten kritisch
gesehen auch wenn die impfverordnung das
so vorsieht
das problem ist eben die tatsache dass
wir uns nicht konzentrieren können auf
die älteren gruppen sollte dass wir
jetzt sehr viel befasst sind mit
beratungen im zusammenhang mit denen die
jetzt davon gebrauch machen wollen und
sich eben auch als jüngere schon eine
auffrischimpfung abholen wollen streit
gibt es auch um die jüngsten in einigen
bundesländern ist die masken pflicht im
unterricht gefallen für lehrer vertreter
zur unzeit sehr viele klassenzimmer sind
ich richtig belastbar die impfquote ist
sehr niedrig noch wir haben keinen
impfstoff für kinder unter zwölf jetzt
auf die masken pflicht zu verzichten
ist nicht nur dumm ich glaube es ist
auch nicht verantwortbar eine impfung
wie sie demnächst wohl in den usa für
kinder ab fünf jahren möglich ist könnte
die situation entspannen jede fünfte
person hilft uns dass insgesamt die lage
in deutschland besser wird was das
infektionsgeschehen angeht und natürlich
haben wir dann auch ein mehr gewinn für
die sicherheit in schulen eine
entscheidung ob es die genehmigung auch
in europa gibt wird noch in diesem jahr
erwartet
in russland des die korona lage gerade
besonders dramatisch ab heute gilt
deshalb ein landesweiter zwangsurlaub
seit wochen steigen die zahlen die
behörden vermelden heute wieder einen
neuen höchstwert 40 1251 neue
infektionen innerhalb eines tages und es
sterben immer mehr menschen
1160 bin 24 stunden und das sind nur die
offiziellen angaben eine ursache die
impfquote ist niedrig die impfskepsis
hoch für begann
waschen füttern windeln wechseln bei
schwerkranken corona patientinnen das
lernen diese freiwilligen in moskau
vorbereitungen auf ihren einsatz in der
roten zone wie kowitz stationen hier
heißen dass dort helfer gebraucht werden
erfuhren sie in der kirche
es war ein aufruf wie während des
krieges sich dem dienst der kirche in
der roten zone anzuschließen sechs
autostunden weiter östlich auch für die
mediziner innen in bor ist es
mittlerweile wie ein krieg russland
gegen die delta fälle in
friedenszeiten hat unser krankenhaus 4
130 betten jetzt sind es 800 dafür haben
wir ein paar abteilungen reduziert die
wir nicht brauchen in friedenszeiten
öffnen wir sie wieder
in einigen regionen werden die
lagerstätten für die toten knapp in
anderen fehlt es an sauerstoff und
überall vermelden sie die pandemie
bekommt ein jüngeres gesicht mehr
kleinkinder mehr säuglinge werden
eingeliefert ich bin ja es ist ihr und
der schweregrad hat zugenommen die
älteren kinder teenager müssen häufiger
mit sauerstoff versorgt werden auch die
krankheitsdauer hat sich verlängert
die antwort des russischen präsidenten
er schickt sein volk in die ferien
sieben tage arbeitsfrei um die
infektionskette zu unterbrechen
in moskau gilt seit donnerstag zudem ein
teil lockdown der genau so lückenhaft
ist wie die einhaltung der masken
pflicht etwa in der u-bahn dazu kommen
umfrageergebnisse wonach sich die
mehrheit der russinnen nicht impfen
lassen will insgesamt eine tödliche
mischung
eigentlich wäre matthias maurer ab
morgen im all aber der deutsche
astronaut muss sich noch gedulden denn
die nase hat seinen flug zur
internationalen raumstation auf mittwoch
verschoben wegen eines heranziehenden
sturmtiefs das macht den start vom
weltraumbahnhof in cape canaveral zu
gefährlich unterdessen hat ein
unbemannter russischer raumtransporter
an der iss angedockt erbrachte
treibstoff und verpflegungsstationen
ebenfalls im gepäck weihnachtsgeschenke
für die besatzung der raumstation
kommenden nacht ist es wieder soweit die
uhr wird umgestellt dabei hatte die eu
doch beschlossen schluss damit die
menschen wollen dass wir machen das
sagte der damalige kommissionschef
juncker nach einer eu-weiten
bürgerbefragung geändert hat sich
seitdem nichts denn 27 eu-staaten sind
sich uneins wie sie das umsetzen sollen
oliver decker
es wird mal wieder an der uhr gedreht
eine stunde zurück von der sommer in die
normalzeit doch eine aktuelle
forsa-umfrage zeigt 78 prozent der
deutschen würden das gerne abschaffen
wenn man sie mal wieder umgewöhnen muss
und die ist im sommer zeit zu unheimlich
schön bis zu wenig zu haben ist es immer
blöd das ist dann halt immer wieder
etwas worauf man achten muss man leicht
durcheinander kommen ich finde die
zeitumstellung bisher antiquiert das ist
ja heute nicht mehr notwehr nicht man
hat früher gemacht weil man glaubte
strom zu sparen tatsächlich ist der
energiespareffekt marginal das belegen
zahlreiche studien ein klarer nachteil
auch das zeigt eine studie 30 prozent
der befragten klagen wegen der
uhrumstellung über gesundheitliche
beschwerden an erster stelle stehen
müdigkeit niedergeschlagenheit
schlappheit
dann gibt es aber auch einen
beachtlichen anteil 67 prozent der
menschen die an schlafstörungen oder
schlafstörungen haben und
konzentrationsprobleme schon 2019
beschloss das eu-parlament die
zeitumstellung abzuschaffen es sagt an
den mitgliedstaaten wie können sich
bisher nicht einigen so will sich die
bundesregierung noch nicht festlegen was
hier gelten soll sommer oder normalzeit
zitat zentral wäre eine koordinierte
möglichst einheitliche und für den eu
binnenmarkt weitgehend harmonisierte eu
regelung seit 1980 werden in deutschland
und vielen weiteren eu-staaten zweimal
im jahr die uhren umgestellt die frage
ist ob und wann für die zeitumstellung
das letzte stündlein schlägt aktuell
stehen die zeiger in der eu auf
stillstand
zum fussball norbert da sind die frauen
des fc bayern ja erfolgreicher als die
männer die sind ja schon in der zweiten
runde rausgeflogen die münchnerinnen
dagegen die haben heute das
viertelfinale erreicht durch einen 4 2
sieg gegen frankfurt den deutschen
meisterin gelang damit die revanche für
die niederlage deutlich in der
bundesliga
die jubelnde bayern fans beim pokal die
frauen machen es möglich dass eins zu
null für münchen nach 27 minuten durch
lehrer schüler elf minuten später
gelingt julia gewinn mit diesem
abstauber das 2 0
dann allerdings kommen die
frankfurterinnen erstmals vor das
gegnerische tor zog genüssen zum 21 in
der zweiten hälfte sind es erneut die
münchnerinnen die druck machen klarer
büßt dropkick ins linke eck 3 zu 1 aber
es bleibt spannend der anschlusstreffer
zum 3 2 ein sehenswerter heber von laura
feiersinger
der letzte treffer erneut durch die
nationalspielerin klara buhl zum 4 2 für
bayern münchen
ja und die münchner männer die haben
nach dem pokal debakel am mittwochen
gladbach heute einen souveränen sieg in
berliner rungen union verliert gegen
bayern mit 225 dortmund schlägt köln 20
freiburg bezwingt führt mit 3 zu 1
leverkusen unterliegt wolfsburg mit 2 zu
0 ein toller einstand für den neuen vfl
trainer florian kufeld bielefeld 1 1 1 2
und das abendspiel frankfurt gegen
leipzig bereits gestern besiegte
hoffenheim die hertha mit 2 0 die
tabelle ganz oben alles unverändert bei
münchen führt mit einem punkt vorsprung
auf dortmund freiburg dritter leverkusen
vierter mainz jetzt fünfter vor union
und wolfsburg die zweite tabellenhälfte
die beginnt mit köln ja und ganz unten
auch alles unverändert augsburg vor
bielefeld und schlusslicht führt und das
abendspiel frankfurt gegen leipzig
ausführlich bei uns zu sehen im
aktuellen sportstudio um 23 uhr david
raum hoffenheims fußball-nationalspieler
da ist zu gast bei jochen breyer
tennis olympiasieger alexander zverev
hat beim hallenturnier in wien das
finale erreicht der hamburger setzte
sich in nur 69 minuten gegen den spanier
carlos alcaraz mit 6 zu 3 6 3 durch
es wird gewinnt das halbfinale souverän
und lässt dem spanischen teenager talent
auf der anderen seite nur punktuell die
ein oder andere chance der aktuell beste
deutsche tennisspieler der neben
olympiagold in tokio in diesem jahr drei
weitere turniere gewann ist in allen
belangen überlegen er holt mehr punkte
beim aufschlag des gegners macht kaum
fehler hat mehr breakpunkte und schlägt
mehr asse eins davon kommt zum einsatz
beim matchball glatten zweisatzsieg
der 24 jahre alte jetzt werde es kann am
sonntag seinen 18 turniersieg holen so
viele wieder frühere wimbledon-sieger
michael stich in seiner ganzen karriere
zverev trifft morgen im finale auf den
us amerikaner francis thema franken und
wir werfen noch einen kurzen blick aufs
wetter morgen tagsüber meist trocken und
teilweise mit werder zugleich von özden
terli das heute-journal können sie heute
um 23.15 sehen mit bettina schausten
tschüss sagen sie es gut
[Musik]
schon goethe und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter das nächste tief steht auf dem
programm und das nähert sich von westen
her bringt dieses regengebiet mit und
das erreicht uns dann morgen abend vor
allem und dahinter fließt kühlere luft
und so wird es in der kommenden woche
nicht mehr so mild sein schauen wir in
die nacht da gibt es im westen regen der
wird allmählich nachlassen ist nicht
mehr viele ansonsten im osten viele
wolken nach südosten klart es auf dort
geht es auf zwei grad zurück aber meist
ist es frostfrei im westen deutlich
milder bei elf grad ja und schon morgen
erst einmal im nordwesten schauer die
lassen allmählich nach sonst gibt es
viele wolken nach osten sonnenschein
genauso wie im südosten hier richtung
bayern viel sonne dieser regen hier der
kommt dann erst am späten nachmittag und
in den abendstunden von westen her
reingezogen temperaturen erreichen
höchstwerte bis 20 grad im südwesten
deutschlands und 13 grad ganz im norden
aber schauen sie es wird häufig mild mit
temperaturen von 14 bis 19 grad ja die
nächsten tage am montag ist es
durchwachsen mit regen nach süden bei
neun bis 15 grad darauf die die
darauffolgenden tage währenden deutlich
kühler dienstag 8 bis 14 mit schauern
und mittwoch nur noch vier bis elf grad
ein schöner abend